or maybe there's not a computerized
voice this time
you're good to go thanks representatives
okay thank you
good morning everyone representative
michael boze
from epping and i remind everyone that
a successful zoom meeting can happen
only if everybody stays muted
so please click your mute
as chair of the house science technology
and energy committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to
executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a committee
orientation meeting please note that
there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i also confirm that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through their zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been available
in the house calendar has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar
on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house house rules
anyone who has a problem accessing the
271-3600
or email h c
s at ledge
dot state dot n h dot
u s in the event that the public is
unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
that's jennifer four our committee
researcher
good morning jennifer please note that
all votes
that are taken during this meeting will
be done by a roll call
vote i do not anticipate that we will
take any
votes during this meeting
we will now start the meeting by taking
a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
that's required
under the right to know law it's
perfectly okay for somebody to be there
we just need to know about it and
remember to
turn your mute button or click your mute
button to turn your microphone on
when you hear your name called so i now
turn the floor
over to representative troy mirner
i'll start right at the top
here representative bresny here and
there's nobody else in the room with me
representative bernard bernardi
here
representative chambles
i believe he was unable to make this
meeting this morning previously cleared
representative notter hi everyone hi
donna hi karen
representative homeland good morning i'm
present
i'm currently alone in my home although
i have a husband working a daughter
going to school and a son
starting school as well thank you
representative samsich
uh yes i'm here and i'm here all alone
by myself at home
representative spy representative
christian i'm here and my two
representative mcgee morning everyone
i'm here and i'm alone
representative mick williams
good morning i'm here and my daughter
representative oxingham
good morning i'm present and i am alone
representative paschall uh
present and my wife may be wandering in
representative pittman i'm here
and uh there are two other people in
in the house my wife and sister which
they may pass through but right now i'm
alone
representative vincent
and finally chairman vose
i am present and i am alone at my home
okay we have um three
absences so we have uh 17
participants um
yes mr representative paul's closeoz
uh i am present alone in the room
i believe i either missed my
call roll call or uh it has not been
called
but nope you didn't miss anything your
i think that was an oversight uh troy
sorry about that no problem i
will put him in i i do have him listed i
just
thank you for informing us of that
oversight and please plan
again
that's okay all right let's move on
thank you for doing the role
representative murder i appreciate that
so i want to just uh
say welcome to everybody to the kickoff
meeting
for the science technology and energy
committee for the
2021-2022 biennium
i'm honored to be your chair for this uh
session
and looking forward to a a really
enjoyable and exciting
year it's going to be a challenging year
however
as we will uh touch upon
during the course of this meeting
because of the unique circumstances
under which we
are meeting in case you haven't heard
we're honored to have representative
douglas thomas of londonderry as the
vice chair of the committee this year
chairman thomas says vice chairman
thomas has done
a lot of behind the scenes work to set
up this meeting
and to do organizational work
to get our community up and running
we have asked representative fred plett
of goffstown to be the clerk of the
committee
as you may have noticed representative
flett is not here this morning
representative plett has been in the
hospital
fighting covet 19 for the better part of
the last
five weeks he's currently in a
rehabilitation hospital doing physical
and occupational therapy
and is improving day by day
he hopes to be able to start discharging
his duties again
by around the end of january early part
of february we wish
fred the best as he continues his
we will be having a second orientation
meeting
a week from today at the same time 10
o'clock
that meeting will feature presentations
from the department of environmental
services
and from the public utilities commission
today's session after
some discussion this morning about how
the committee will
operate this year will feature two
presentations
one by the consumer advocate the office
of the consumer advocate don
crease and another by
the iso new england representative
who is a person familiar to veteran
members of this committee
kate epson she will be here about noon
time
mr chair yes sir representative thomas
if if i may uh i would like to um
explain that we have on a temporary
basis on our committee
uh representative susan hamola who
is filling in for representative plent
until such time as he feels he can uh
join us at uh full strength i just want
to make it clear that
that she's an authorized member of our
committee
uh on a temporary basis thank you
representative thomas uh
and i apologize to representative homola
for forgetting to
to mention that but thank you uh
representative thomas
and thank you to troy mariner for uh
volunteering to
be the clerk in fred plett's absence
all right i would like to before we go
into any further discussions about how
the committee will operate this year i'd
like to
turn the uh the podium as
as it uh exists over to
jennifer poor four or rather for a
presentation by the house staff so
jennifer it's all yours
before i take over um it looks like
representative notter has a question for
you perhaps representative fos
representative notter thank you sorry
the room that came in the room i'm sorry
it's loud
um next friday at 10 a.m is the
hillsborough county
executive meeting so i'm on the
executive board
so i wouldn't you will not be able to
okay jennifer hi
um i'm happy to be with the science and
tech committee for the first time today
um as i think most if not all of you
know um
joel anderson after i think 33 years
retired at the end of the year
we miss him very much um and for the
time being
his former committees are being covered
by one of the remaining um staff of
researchers
so i currently staff
ways and means education judiciary
fish and game and science and tech
so if i ever mistakenly send you an
invitation for one of those committees
let me know right away um
i'm happy to be here um for
those of you who are new to the
legislature welcome
and um i'm part of the house committee
research staff
i am also also hold the title of
committee council
um so i'm available to all of the chairs
to help with any
more in-depth legal research um
i our office is part of house committee
services which also offers
clerical support um it houses the
committee assistants who help
with scheduling and
all parts of processing bills as they
for the research piece all research
requests are directed through the chair
um authorized by the chair and then they
come to me
just to keep things organized and so
that the chair is aware
of any research requests that come up um
i'm excited to get to learn about your
content area i'm
certainly haven't had a lot of exposure
in the past so
bear with me but i'm happy to help
connect you
with experts in the field points of
contact in the agencies
that help you guys anything i can do
to help make this as smoothly as
possible understanding that we're doing
everything just a little bit differently
so i'm happy to take any questions that
there might be uh regarding house
committee services
representative sumsitch yes uh thank you
very much jennifer i just wanted to
clarify
um you mentioned that when it comes to
requesting any kind of research
we should go through the chairman um
i assume that doesn't mean that if we
have questions about to you about
various smaller issues we don't have to
go through the chairman for that i
assume
that's correct that would be kind of
cumbersome so
can you can you kind of explain the
difference when we should go through the
chairman and when we don't need to do
that
sure that's an excellent point um so if
you're looking at a bill and
so you just have a specific question
about a bill or have a question
about finding a certain citation where
can i see
you know the rest of the law that that
this would fall into
um can you get me a phone number for
such and such a person
things like that i'm happy to take on
individually um if there's going to be a
more
lengthy in-depth memo that needs to be
generated um
just a more substantial research project
that should
that should go through the chair okay
all right thank you guys i'm going to
stay on the call i'll just turn off my
video though
thank you jennifer thank you very much
jen
all right so i'd like to spend a little
bit of time now talking about some
specifics about how we operate the
committee
on a daily basis
we're also going to talk about uh
the way house leadership envisions the
committee process
unfolding this year and it's going to be
quite different
from what we have experienced in the
past
but before we get to that one of our
traditions in this committee
at the start of every day is to
do the pledge of allegiance we did not
do the pledge of allegiance this morning
because of the unusual nature of the
uh of this meeting but i would like to
now
call on representative doug thomas to
lead us in the pledge
of allegiance and i would like you all
to
mute your microphone and say the the
pledge
uh in the privacy of your home and
follow along with
representative thomas thank you
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which stands one
nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you representative thomas we will
always begin our meetings with
a pledge
so let's talk a little bit about the
committee meetings themselves when will
they happen
in the past those of us who have been on
this committee
for some time uh have gotten used to two
and sometimes three committee meetings a
week
but due to the uh nature of the covet 19
pandemic
and the need to keep people safe and to
restrict
how we gather where we gather and when
we gather
house leadership has determined that
committees will only be allowed to meet
we have not yet been assigned a day of
the week
it will probably be monday a tuesday
or a wednesday possibly a friday
we will let you know as soon as we know
so that you can clear your schedules
for that particular day
our meetings will start at nine o'clock
in the morning
and they will run until five o'clock in
the afternoon
we will try to take a couple of breaks
during the day
we have 32 bills to vet over the course
of approximately six weeks
and therefore
our meeting days will be long we will be
looking at
doing four five or six public hearings
per day on the days we meet
some of those public hearings may be
short some may be long
but you can count on our meeting days
being quite long
so where will we meet the house is
currently
house leadership is currently setting up
a system
whereby committees will be allowed to
meet
in a double-sized room and the
and that room will have tables set up
so that legislators can be socially
distanced
there is some uh talk also about the
possibility that the
the rooms may have plexiglass
installed between members
uh to further uh isolate
members from each other
attendance at these meetings will be
optional that these in-person meetings
will be
optional if you would prefer to
attend the meeting via zoom that option
will be available to you
but if you want to attend in person you
they will only be allowing two
committees per
floor per day so
on the day that our committee meets
there will be one other committee
meeting on the same floor
and there will be two committees meeting
on the floor below or above
the one we will be assigned to
so there will be very limited
um numbers of
people in the building attendance will
be limited to
members and staff the general public
will not be allowed to attend in person
so all presentations to the committee
will be done
via electronic delivery
there will be a 60 inch monitor monitor
in the committee room
so that people who attend the committee
meeting via
uh in person rather will will listen to
all the presentations
on the video screen
that's in the room people attending the
meeting via zoom will see it on their on
their home screen
so there will be no members of the
public and no
presenters who attend the meeting
this is going to be a very different way
of doing things and
our first couple of meetings
basically amount to an experiment to see
how well this is going to work
but we will all work hard to try to make
it work
because it's in all of our best
interests to do so it will keep us safe
and that's of paramount importance to
house leadership
and to the leadership of this committee
so
i want everybody to feel comfortable
want everybody to feel safe
and we will do everything we can to make
sure that that
happens
if you do decide to attend the committee
meeting
in person we encourage you to
follow traditional house rules about
dress and dress business casual
for men that typically means ties and
sport goats
and for women there's a plethora
of business casual options that
i'm sure all of the members of this
committee
when we address members uh and
each other uh and members of the public
we follow rules of decorum
we request permission of the chair
to speak and uh
when we ask a question we thank the
person who's
receiving the question for taking the
question
and we thank them for their answer once
they've
given us a question or giving us an
answer
as was noted earlier when we do have
executive sessions and votes
all votes will be via roll call
members who are in the room
will vote simply by answering the call
of the
of the clerk members online will vote
the same way
but they will have to remember to unmute
their microphones before they
as in the past if you are attending a
meeting
in person no food will be allowed
in the committee room you can bring
a bottle of water um but
you won't be allowed to eat in the
committee room
we will make arrangements for taking a
lunch break
during the course of a long eight hour
day
and we will let you know where in the
building
it is permissible to eat once we know
that ourselves right now we don't know
if you do have to leave the committee
room
during the course of a a meeting
you were you will be required to wear a
mask so if you need to go to the
restroom as you walk out of the
committee room into the hallway you
should put on a mask
you can remove the mask once you return
portable electronics are also allowed in
the committee room
iphones and or phones um
pads but we discourage their use
on a routine basis checking your email
looking at facebook we discourage that
it's okay if you need to look something
up
do some research during the course of a
public hearing
but um please don't sit there on your
phone the whole time
uh that you're engaged in a public
hearing
i'm going to go over some other
guidelines that we've been
developing for public hearings
and as i indicated before this is uh
these guidelines that we've come up with
are ideas that we think will help
facilitate
given the extreme conditions under which
we're going to be meeting
long committee days many many public
hearings in a single day
occasionally during a
session day we will also have
those can be called at any time and will
be called
during the course of our meetings so
that we can dispose of our bills
but because of these tough conditions
we're likely going to have to come up
with some different rules about how to
operate a public hearing
so some broad outlines that we've come
up with
are as follows anybody planning to
testify
before the committee should submit
written testimony to the committee
now we've always encouraged written
testimony in the past
but this year we're going to make
written testimony a mandate because
we're going to have to probably restrict
verbal testimony so in order for
someone to provide us with the most
and the best information possible about
a given bill
they're going to need to produce a
written document
now some people already do this
department agencies uh and department
representatives frequently submit
written testimony it's very thorough
and very useful and helpful
other people less so
in terms of their written testimony but
this year we're going to try to
encourage people to
do as much written testimony as possible
a prime sponsor who introduces a bill
will be permitted
five minutes to introduce the
legislation
you'll be encouraged to highlight three
or four important points from their
written
testimony and limit it
to that because five minutes goes by
pretty quickly
for or against the bill will be limited
to
three minutes and they'll be encouraged
to highlight maybe two points
anybody who is testifying
and repeats points made by a previous
committee members will be allowed two
questions
for a presenter and any follow-up
question must arrive directly from an
answer to a previous question
statements like uh would you believe
that do not provide immediate contacts
for a question
must not proceed will not be accepted
they will not be allowed and members
must not
engage in debate with presenters but
shall endeavor only to clarify
factual information presented
[Music]
so i'm seeing that we've already uh got
some questions out there so
um let's answer a couple of questions
before we
we move on here uh representative
jackie callie pitts do you have a
question yes i do
um the the testimony that we're going to
require
i have a comment one is i think it's
going to
hamper some of the general public that
report and secondly how do we how are we
going to get copies
of this testimony so that we can go over
it
thank you for that question uh i
anticipate
that if presenters comply with our
requirement to
uh submit written written testimony 24
hours in advance that we would
distribute that testimony to all members
of the committee by
email so that they would have time
to read it digest it formulate questions
that they want to
ask before the actual committee vote and
if
you know we'll encourage people to
submit their test
written testimony even um
more in advance than 24 hours if they if
they want
the sooner they submit written testimony
the better we can distribute it to all
the members of the committee
and people will have more time to read
it and digest it
remember to mute your uh yourself
once you've finished speaking
representative samson your question yes
thank you mr chairman
uh you mentioned um the this
scenario of meeting in person in these
committee rooms
at the lob so i have
two questions here and number one my
understanding is that the lop
has been determined to be an unhealthy
building
due to a lack of air circulation
so i don't know how we can ensure that
the building is actually a
safe building to meet in and second if i
understood you correctly you mentioned
that
mass squaring would not be required in
the committee
room while where we are meeting but only
in the
the hallways and when when exits to go
to the rare house room is that correct
thank you for those uh questions
representative sanchez
to your first question the house
leadership has
and house staff has recently installed
ultraviolet light air purifiers
ultraviolet
radiation air purifiers throughout all
the committee rooms in the house
they so i'm told
they clean the air five times per hour
and the house staff has determined
how staff and leadership is determined
that that will do an
adequate job to uh cleaning the air
so that house the legislative office
building
committee rooms will be safe to use
with regard to mask wearing since
members will be separated from each
other by a minimum of six feet
and possibly by plexiglas barriers
it is going to be permissible to remove
your mask
once you are sitted seated at in your
seat
at the committee roundtable because
um between the air purifying technology
and the distance you'll be residing
between yourself and another member
plus the barriers that will be in place
house leadership feels comfortable that
that will be
sufficient to protect members from
the spread of any disease
uh mr chairman i just can i just clarify
this again
um being that we are the science
technology energy committee
i would be very interested in
specifications and
and details about what these uh
ultraviolet
uh machines are are who makes them who
certifies them
and whether we have an independent um
certification that this is an effective
way of removing
i worked for a company that made uv
lights so i know something about them
but
this is a unique situation with the
virus
i don't think that any uh uh staff
that's not technically competent to
evaluate it can say one way or the other
whether it's going to be safe or not
i'd like to have some professional
people certify this to us
and i'd like to get a little more uh
specifications about those that
equipment
thank you representative sanchez that's
a reasonable request i will
try to comply with it i will talk to
house leadership about
getting such documentation thank you
very much
oh yes i was just going to add that the
um
the use of the machines and being in the
building has been cleared by the state
hhs and medical doctor for being safe to
use
and again uh i would defer
asking more specific questions to the
house leadership
they're the ones that have been in
consultation for weeks and weeks
to make sure that everything was in
compliance
thank you representative thomas any
other
representative mann you need to click
your mute button
i thought sorry about that i thought you
could uh read my lips
um the
i'd like to go back to peter sam's which
is uh representative samson's point
um we're all responsible for our own
health
and i think if we're not satisfied
any of us not satisfied with being
present
i certainly don't want to risk my life
on
some person who uh you know in this new
virus that we
i don't want to be part of the
experiment that proves one way or
another
was there a question there
representative manager
oh sorry about that it was a statement
okay thank you very much appreciate that
thanks for taking my question chair bose
um i just want to clarify how the
process will go for asking questions of
presenters during hearings
you said that you're limiting the number
of questions to each of the
representatives to two questions is that
correct
yes thank you for the question that is
correct and is there a time limit for
questions
no we haven't come up with a specific
time limit for questions
typically a question doesn't take that
long uh
there will be about a one to two minute
limit
on the answer to the question from the
presenter
but the question itself i hadn't
anticipated that we need we would need
to put a time limit on
on the question itself
thank you yes thank you
any additional questions
thank you mr chairman and that is oxenum
thank you
uh two things uh follow-up to
representative samson's question he
asked about the air quality which is
completely separate
from uh the covet issue the the building
has been determined not to have air
circulation
i i would ask that that also be looked
into
and the second part was about the limit
on questions
will it be one question from people in
the room and one question from those
that aren't in the room will it be one
question from a republican one question
from a democrat is there any
uh process there thank you very much for
taking the question
thank you for those uh questions an
answer to your first
question
we will disseminate any information that
we get from house leadership
about the quality
of the environment in
the legislative office building as
representative thomas pointed out
dhhs and some medical doctors have
evaluated the building with its new um
uv radiation cleansing machines
and determine that it's safe i would
remind everybody
that attendance at the lob is optional
so
if you don't feel safe just stay home
and attend
our public hearings via zoom uh
that should work for just about
everybody
this hybrid model should make it safe
for everybody
but also uh make the public hearing
process
as open and as informative
as it can be some people prefer
being in attendance with other people
when they're in a public hearing
other people might choose to stay home
because they feel they're safer that way
so
you have the option of doing either
staff however excuse me staff however
would not have that option
as i understand it they they are
that's a good question i'm not sure the
answer to that i believe staff and
jennifer
she's still on here i can't tell if
she's still on uh
here mr post excuse me thank you uh
jennifer uh can you answer
representative oxenham's question about
right now we have staff
coming in staff working from home
it's a it's a big mixture right now um
and i i don't think i have a better
answer than that i'm in the building
right now
but i could be working from home um
for instance i'll be working from home
next week
in terms of running the equipment those
details are still being
sorted out so
it's very likely that a big portion of
staff will continue
working remotely or coming in
one or two days a week mornings things
like that
everyone's on a little bit of a
different schedule
if i made just one more follow-up mr
chairman
yes the question about air circulation
is is
really an important one because you may
be cleaning the air
five times an hour but if it's the same
air
there are other issues uh that that are
that we're putting our staff and those
who choose to be there
at risk and thank you and i'll conclude
thank you representative you raise a
good point and i think what we should do
is we should get clarification and
documentation from
house leadership and dhhs
about these machines and the quality of
the air that they
produce and once we have that
information
and we can share it um broadly with the
members of the committee
um everybody will know where we stand
with that
chairman thank you representative nader
thank you somewhere in my office i have
the paperwork on the machines
i just couldn't find it i even looked in
the other room um i've we've been
assured that
the machines actually kill coven so
and they're putting in extra ones more
than that than was required
for the size of the rooms but again the
thank you representative knotter
representative thomas
i thank you mr chair i just wanted to
add just
just a little bit of information on
people in the building
although this may not happen much or
it may be rare if a representative
is in the building because he or she is
in another committee on that day
and one of that one of the bills that he
or she may have submitted
is up that representative will be
allowed to come into the committee room
in person and introduce that bill
that's only if he was or he or she
happened to be in the building that day
when that bill is being introduced
because
they're in another committee meeting so
i just wanted to get that point
uh across it's um won't happen often i'm
sure but it could happen and you should
be aware that you are able to do that
that word came from the speaker
thank you representative thomas
representative kelly pitts
thank you uh mr chairman i'm i'm
concerned about the limit on the number
of questions
since because i know from experience
presenters especially the ones who are
employees of various companies etc
sometimes know very artfully how to
escape or to
uh convolute an issue and that
you sometimes you need to get vacation
especially on issues that we deal with
it's not cut and dry
so i i'm concerned about that it's going
to
limit the ability to the matter and some
of
these issues that we deal with and i
want to know if that's hard and fast
thank you for that expression of concern
and i will say that none of these rules
none of these guidelines that i've gone
over here this morning are hard and fast
this whole process is brand new to all
of us
so we're going to have to try it
and see what works the overriding
concern here is we're only meeting once
a week and if we have 32 bills to do
that means basically we have to
have public hearings on five or six
bills
every week now in order to get those
public hearings in
we may have to limit the number of
questions that get asked
we may have to limit the length of
testimony that gets offered
and it's simply a matter of getting
through the day
and it is these guidelines that i just
spoke about
uh while we will follow them initially
if for some reason we determine they're
not working and we can come up with a
better way of doing things
we'll do that but we've got to
have some kind of a system in place if
we're going to have any chance
of getting through all 32 bills during
the course
of six what amounts to about six
committee session days so
i urge everyone's to be
everyone to be um
understanding about our situation i urge
everyone to pitch in
and try to to help us all do the best
that we can to get through
this difficult time um
the house deadlines are hard and fast we
have to be done with all of our
committee work by march 23rd i think the
date is
so we have we have few options here
uh if we're going to be restricted to
just one day a week
so mr chair all right representative
thomas
yes thank you um thank you for uh
recognizing me
uh i uh if if you will i would just like
to make a general statement uh perhaps
more so
for our uh attendees and um
people that might be bringing um
you know testimony to our floor on a
regular basis
i know i think everyone here that's been
here knows in the past
sometimes sometimes uh time is taken up
by
going over his history uh
maybe they're lamenting on certain
things that may have happened or didn't
happen before in the past
that takes up a lot of time i would
suggest
for people that are giving testimony
that they get right to the point
of what they really want to say and what
the points are that are really important
for them
either in support of or not support of a
certain bill
and that should take away a lot of
time that they may have used before in
the past
i think it's important this year that we
work together
to get through this and understand that
it's not business as usual and we're
trying to be consistently fair
across the entire spectrum so uh just
like we
may need to limit our type or length of
questions
i would ask the attendees to consider uh
the most important points that they need
to get across
realizing that they have the written
testimony to fill in the
you know the extra information it's a
okay thank you representative thomas we
have any more
questions or important points to make
about
our situation here uh representative
oxenom
yeah thank you very much mr chair on
this question uh
again of if if you're the prime sponsor
and you want to bring experts to testify
in support of your bill are are they
limited
in the same way as the questions are and
secondarily i didn't really get an
answer to the earlier question about the
two
people allowed to question whether they
would be one republican one democrat
one person out of the room one person in
the room one personal lobbyist one
person a member of the public
is there any hard and fast or at least
guideline on that
thank you uh for that question
representative
i didn't say that questions would be
limited to two people i said
each member will be limited to two
questions
so every member of the committee all
what 21 of us could ask up to two
questions during the course of a public
hearing
that's a lot of question that's a lot of
time actually um
i'm certainly hopeful that not everybody
not all 21 of us would be would feel it
necessary to ask questions and hopefully
if we get good written testimony
submitted ahead of time
we won't have to ask that many questions
i urge you all to remember every
question you ask
makes the public hearing last longer and
the longer the public hearing lasts
the longer our days become and the more
difficult
uh our weekly sessions near the end of
the uh as we approach the house deadline
the more difficult our sessions will
become
so the reason we came up with a
guideline for questions
is to not to discourage people from
asking them
we certainly want people to get as much
information as possible
but just to be thoughtful about how
often you ask a question how many
questions you ask
and be
be thoughtful of the time constraints
so i answered that part of your question
representative and now i forgot the
you and me both thank you very much that
was very helpful
okay thank you uh representative mann
this is the whole thing i'll have to
have a mallet to hit myself on the head
with
um it it's clear that there's something
an ability of a zoom called screen chair
so it is possible
for uh me at home for example to give a
presentation that might have some
visuals
and uh people are testifying
um other people might also
want to use visuals and
whether this the screen share could be
somehow used
you know a video captured by video at
the uh
at the at the uh
at the legislative office building
and therefore transmitted to everybody
else that
is watching or somebody is asking a good
question or giving a presentation from
their home remotely they could also do
um a presentation just by having the
information put on a on a on powerpoint
or something like that instead of
on a large piece of um of
parchment so anyway the question is
basically if people looked into that
and it does seem to me it would be an
easy
and easy process
well thank you for that query uh
representative
i can tell you that we will be
discouraging screen sharing
uh during presentations for the simple
reason that they will
dramatically increase the time that it
will take to make a presentation
instead we will encourage people to
submit materials
as part of their written testimony so if
they have
graphs or tables or
other audio visual materials that they
want to share
we encourage we will encourage them to
share that by their written testimony
and will discourage the use of screen
sharing
during uh public hearing testimony
representative partial yes thank you mr
chairman uh and also thank you for
making the action available
through hybrid meetings i appreciate
that
my question is um
written testimony will be disseminated
to uh representatives
um on the committee within 24 hours
but how will this information be
disseminated to attendees
is that been given some thought i'm sure
it is
thank you for that question
representative no we haven't given that
any thought because
typically it's not the committee's
responsibility to
share information with attendees
we only share information with other
members of the committee
it would be up to the presenter to share
information with
other people in whatever manner they
choose to do so
thank you i'll have more questions for
my uh for our
later on but thank you so much you're
very welcome thank you
thank you mr chairman i took my hand
down and didn't take the mute off
nice to see everyone again um my
question was around i had heard that the
senate
um who's a little smaller and more
nimble they they've
adopted their processes around hearings
rather quickly
and i my question was they're using um
an online form which is similar to the
blue sheets so that people can sign in
on the hearing in terms of whether
they're in support or
opposed to a particular piece of
legislation
and so i was wondering if there has been
any discussion about the house adopting
that type of an
option through our website and also
on the policy of folks who want to
testify being aware that they need to
submit things within a certain time
frame in order to be eligible to testify
if that's going to be something that we
try to use and i do
i do very much understand
the need to try and keep the um the
hearing
uh testimony especially concise and so i
appreciate that
um but will there be policy listed so
the public
understands how their access is supposed
to work
um and one last thing so i'll just get
it all out and then you can
you can deal with it and i'll try to
remember my my points
um you had mentioned that if someone
who's testifying starts repeating a
point that's already been brought up
that they basically would get the hook
and i i appreciate that too i wish we
had had that last term
but um but i'm curious uh if you could
say a little
more about how that type of a rule would
be applied
because i think what we do see is that
i think that our people who give
testimony in our committee especially
those who are repeat
um you know the lobbyists the folks who
know the issues
i think they're usually pretty good
about saying i'm not going to repeat
something that someone else has already
mentioned
but i just wondered if you could say a
little more about how that would be
applied because we do have
in-person versus online audiences so um
so i'm just wondering how that would be
done if someone's online will they just
be muted or
how will it happen thank you for your
question
representative the first part of your
question about the senate's
policy we are aware of it and house
leadership is working on a
policy for the house we have
pink cards and blue sheets that we
need to replicate in an online
system of some sort i know the staff is
working on those
i do not know at this point in time
what solution they've come up with they
haven't announced it to us yet
but that is being
investigated and dealt with
to your question about people getting
the hook
which is a good way to put it obviously
um we will be respectful
but if someone starts repeating points
that i've heard before i'm just going to
simply ask the presenter to suspend
and then i will ask them if they have
any new points
to offer rather than repeating points
that have already been made
and give them that opportunity if they
choose to make a fresh point then we'll
let them but if they choose to
to repeat points that have already been
to end their testimony and move on to
the next person
as i said before this is all an
have to make the best of it to do the
best we can with it so
we are going to need to move on very
soon
to our first presenter which is uh
the office of the consumer advocate so
i will call on those three people and
then we'll move on if that's okay with
uh
with everybody on the committee so
representative samsich uh
go ahead yes thank you mr chairman i
just have a quick point i
totally agree with your your effort to
try to streamline everything as far as
the questions are concerned
however i would like to point out that
our committee
when it comes to these bills we are the
primary
screening process for all these bills
there's not going to be much debate on
the floor we know that
so we need to do as good a job as we can
within the time constraints to figure
out these
bills and figure out what they do and
what they don't do
and that's our job that's our primary
job so
i think the way to deal with that is we
need to make a bigger effort to focus
our
questions as precisely as possible in a
short
amount of time but we do need to get the
information needed for these bills
very good point and i thank you for that
representative thomas
yes thank you mr chair i just wanted to
say primarily for benefit of the
freshmen that are on here
in the past on a particularly important
bill
many times the public feels that
by by having
10 maybe 15 people come down
to show support for the bill that they
all have to speak on it
and generally the information that
becomes repetitive is they tell
they tell us uh basically how they're
affected
and it's generally the same type of
information although
everyone's situation is you know
different perhaps
we could help that by asking either the
attendees or any other organization that
is uh asking people to support
or not support us a certain bill to
be mindful of that fact and we would
love to have their written testimony
if it is the same thing then perhaps
only
perhaps only two or three that show the
uh
the indications of how this bill is
affecting them would be sufficient in
terms of speaking
and the rest of the written testimonies
could be just supportive in
information that might be one way that
we can handle
uh people that have uh we should only do
since they don't have to drive the two
or three hours sometimes to come down
and testify
and they can be behind their computer um
they may feel a little better about the
fact that their point gets across by
a few representative people uh that's
that's what
i would say about that one there thank
plozas
thank you i had a computer glitch
i am now on audio by phone just to
update you
and a question if i may uh
how would you prefer members when they
need to
leave their seat for a moment or two
while we're on
i suggest that if you need to leave your
seat
you just click in the lower left hand uh
corner of your screen the stop video
button i'll show you what happens when
and then you can leave and when you come
back just
click the button again and your video
will resume
okay uh representative mcwilliams you're
you're the last question before we move
thank you chair bose just want to
clarify
can you tell me the time limits again
that you have determined for
any of the pieces of the hearing i just
want to write it down
uh sure i'm going to send these
guidelines out to everybody but
basically prime sponsors will get five
minutes other speakers will be limited
to three minutes
uh and uh committee members will be
limited to two questions for a presenter
thank you very much
okay thank you well thanks very much for
all your questions this has been a
a good discussion as we always have uh
in in this committee i had intended
originally
to go around to every member and has
asked them to introduce themselves
but we got so deeply into the weeds with
questions that we have run out of time
to do that
maybe we will do that next friday for
those in attendance
at the orientation meeting next week
but at this point in time i feel
obligated to
turn the floor over to the office of the
consumer advocate
represented by the consumer advocate
himself
donald crease and he will
do a presentation um on
how electricity rates are
set developed and set uh by the public
utilities commission i believe that's
the subject he wants to talk about
so don crease if you are there uh please
take it away uh i
am here my camera got turned off for
some reason
uh good morning uh chairperson voz
members of the committee it's a great
pleasure to be
here with you this morning i do have
some slides that i'd be happy to share
i don't think they'll slow me down at
all it's just basically
an outline if you prefer that i not
share them i don't have to
it's totally up to you mr chairman it's
perfectly okay this is a presentation
not a not testimony on a bill
super okay i'll bring those up now and
yes yes you them see them excellent so
uh let me just uh first of all say on
the first slide there's my friend ready
kilowatt i'm violating somebody's
trademark by showing him to you
uh i will send this uh uh little slide
deck out to everybody
and you see on the first slide is my
name and contact information
that's my direct line down there on the
bottom and that email address gets right
to me and i
always like to talk to uh legislators
about matters of
public policy that i know something
about
so i want to start
with some basic principles
public utilities are under new hampshire
law
are regulated monopolies meaning that in
your uh wherever you are there's only
going to be one electric company
one gas utility one water company and in
a few places around the state there's
actually a sewer utility so
if you let a monopoly charge uh prices
without any government interference
then obviously the monopolist can
extract what are called monopoly rents
just sort of
charge an unreasonably high price
so the rate regulation is as conducted
by the public utilities commission
is intended to mimic what the
competitive market
would set as the price under principles
of classic microeconomics
if there were actually a competitive
market by statute the puc is
defined as the arbiter between the
interests of the owners and the
shareholders of the regulated
or the excuse me the customers and the
shareholders of their regulated
utilities
uh utilities as you as you might imagine
are very well represented by the puc
they have lots of very talented lawyers
who
advocate on their behalf and a lot of
very knowledgeable
experts and so as in about 45 states
around the country
the general court here in new hampshire
has established a ratepayer advocate
and that is me our job is to represent
the interests of residential customers
at the puc and frankly anywhere else
where the interests of residential
customers
are implicated so the
idea is that we actually help the puc do
its job
by putting some weight on the other side
of its
arbiter scale so the utilities are
vigorously represented and hopefully
residential customers are also
vigorously represented
unlike a lot of my counterparts around
the country i do not represent
the interests of all customers i think
when our office was created the idea was
that commercial and industrial customers
would by virtue of their
economic niche i guess have their own
representation whereas residential
customers would
would not and i also want to stress that
i represent resident
residential customers as a group i do
not represent
individual residential customers i hear
from them from time to time and i try to
help them
but i can't represent them at the puc or
anywhere else
so the bulwark of what the puc does as i
just suggested
is regulate the rates of public
utilities and of course rates are just
the prices that those public utilities
charge and by statute what the puc is
supposed to do
is make sure that rates are just and
reasonable that's a deliberately
vague statutory phrase there is also
on top of that a constitutional
limitation
that is grounded in the uh actually it's
the fifth amendment
and the language in the fifth amendment
that says you cannot take private
property
without just compensation the you being
the governor government
so the constitutional theory here is
that it is possible for a
regulator to set rates that are so low
that they are
considered quote unquote confiscatory in
other words what you have done
in that scenario is in effect taken the
utilities property
and uh not provided just compensation
in the form of reasonable rates so
what does all of that mean well in 1944
the u.s supreme court issued its famous
hope natural gas decision
and declared that rates are not
confiscatory
when a return to the equity owner
meaning the shareholders
are commensurate with the return that
shareholders would earn on
other investments that have the same
degree of
risk associated with them it turns out
the reasonableness of return on
investment
is a function of risk as you all
intuitively know because
if you take a hundred dollars and invest
it uh deposit it at your local bank or
credit union
you're going to earn an extremely low
rate of interest
if you take that same 100 and invest it
in
some high-flying stock on the nasdaq you
are going to expect
a higher rate of return because the risk
that you will lose your investment
is several orders of magnitude higher
and then uh there is my favorite case
which is a 1988 decision of the new
hampshire supreme court
written by david suter back when he was
a member of that court
in which he pointed out that even though
rates can't be uh confiscatory
shareholders of utilities are not
entitled to what he called
plenary indemnification and then he
explained what he meant
uh this was a case in which the owner
the then owner of
the seabrook nuclear power plant which
at the time was public service company
of new hampshire
uh tried to raise its authorized return
on equity
up to 19 and the puc said no you only
get 13
which is already pretty high and uh
public service company lost and justice
suiter explained
that if we just basically as your
investment in seabrook gets riskier and
riskier and riskier
if we just kept right raising the return
on equity that we allow you
the consequence of that would be as he
said nothing less than a shifting of the
entire risk
from investors to the ratepayers and
neither the constitution
nor the statutory requirement of just
reasonable rates
justifies that so how does the public
utilities commission
figure out whether rates are just and
reasonable
well it turns out that because the
statutory standard is quite
vague and because the constitution
doesn't require it
there is no mandated way of setting
rates
but over the years largely through
i guess what i would call case law both
here in new hampshire and
everywhere else around the country the
established method is called
cost of service rate setting and
it works in a pretty straightforward
fashion uh the key determination
in a rate case at the puc is the
utilities avenue annual revenue
requirement
that's just how much money does the
utility need over the course of a
12-month period
in order to uh operate and the way you
figure out what the revenue requirement
is
is you determine what the operating
costs of the company are
you know what how much its payroll costs
uh how much gasoline it needs to buy in
order to fuel its
trucks and you know every other little
operating big or little
operating cost of the company and to
that number
you add a multiple of two other numbers
one of which is the utilities rate base
and the
other of which is the utilities weighted
average cost of capital
so what do we mean by rate base well
basically rate base
is the value of the utilities
uh capital investments the actual
hardware that it uses to provide service
and how do we determine rate base it's
the original cost incurred by the
utility
to build that infrastructure uh minus
a uh because everything
depreciates over time you calculate the
depreciation every year
so that an asset that was built in 1950
is probably fully depreciated by now so
its
uh rate base is probably something close
to zero
uh whereas if a utility puts in say a
huge
transformer at a substation this week
its original cost is going to be in the
tens of millions of dollars and that's
the number that goes into rate base
and it declines over time as the asset
depreciates
and then the other number in the formula
is the weighted average cost of capital
that is a function of the utility's cost
of debt
and the utilities cost of equity and as
i'm guessing most of you know or
what i generally like to say is that
they're really just two flavors of money
there's your money and there's other
people's money so
in the case of a utility the your money
is
the shareholder investment that's equity
and then
other people's money is debt which is
money that you borrow from
other people usually banks and other
lending institutions
so uh the interest that you have to pay
out on your debt
is going to be lower than the return
that your shareholders
are expecting on their equity and you
calculate what a reasonable return on
equity is
you plug in the utilities cost of debt
you weight them depending on
what percentage of the utility is funded
by debt and equity and there you come
out with the weighted average cost of
capital which is basically
the return on the utility's total
investment
you multiply that return by the rate
case you add that to the operating costs
and you come out with the revenue
requirement
but the revenue requirement
determination is
just the first act of what is really a
two-act
play because you have to take that
revenue requirement and apportion it
among the various rate classes what do i
mean by rate classes well
i'm a residential customer uh the
uh dartmouth-hitchcock medical center in
lebanon
is a big commercial and industrial
customer uh
the budweiser plant down in
nashua they're a commercial industrial
customer
your business your dentist's office is a
small
commercial customer and so each
utility divides its customers up into
various classes
and the revenue requirement likewise has
to be divided up amongst those various
classes
how do we do that well basically the uh
idea is that each rate class is supposed
to bear
its reasonable share of what it actually
costs to operate the utility
so the utility does what are called cost
of service studies to try to figure that
out
uh other problems and issues
that drive rate design are to what
extent a utilities revenue requirement
should come via fixed charges
versus variable charges by fixed charges
i mean
when you look on your electric bill
there's a fixed customer charge of uh
you know 13 i think it is in the
eversource territory for
residential customers and you get that
13 charge every month no matter how much
electricity you use
and then there are also variable charges
and by that i mean they vary depending
on how many kilowatt hours of
electricity you use
so what part of the cost do you put in
the variable charges
what party of the cost do you put in the
fixed charges
ideally you put the utilities fixed
costs in the fixed charges
and you put the utilities variable
charges in the variable charges
that's easy to talk about in principle
very hard to do without a lot of
argument and hand-wringing
in reality there are also social equity
principles that come to bear
on uh rate design we don't charge
everybody the same rates even if they're
basically
imposing the same costs on the system
the classic example is that there are
often special rates and programs
available to
uh income eligible customers people who
have trouble paying their
utility bills and then um when you look
at rate when you think about how to
design
rates you also have to consider the
question of price signals
you know what are we what are we
encouraging people to do
or discouraging people from doing based
on the kind
of rates that we're charging them and uh
the example of that that we're talking
about a lot these days
have to do with rates that vary by time
of day and by season
it's much more expensive to produce a
kilowatt hour of electricity
on the hottest day in july at about 5
p.m
than it is on a random april
saturday night at two in the morning
when the cost is
pretty close to zero so do we set our
retail rates to reflect those costs
ideally or theoretically the answer to
that question is yes because we want to
encourage consumption when the resource
is plantable plentiful
and we want to discourage consumption
when it
the the other important question that
bears
upon all of this business of utility
regulation
is what what is the state going to be
able to do
and what is the federal government going
to be able to do
and that question is centered around the
commerce clause of the
u.s constitution which gives congress
the right to regulate
interstate commerce so the federal
government does not have the right to
regulate intrastate commerce
just interstate commerce and then
the other part of the constitution
that's relevant is the
supremacy clause that says that federal
law
is the supreme law of the land so as
long as congress
is acting within its authority to
regulate interstate commerce
when it does act that is the supreme law
of the land
and to the extent state law is
inconsistent with the federal law
that is what's known as preemption
and it means that the state law is void
and the federal law
governs so what do we mean by federal
law
well in the electricity realm we're
principally talking about the federal
power
act and you know again it's a very
complicated scenario but the basic
principles are pretty easy to state
uh the federal energy regulatory
commission regulates
wholesale electricity and interstate
transmission
you know a lot of the vocabulary that we
use in this space
is complicated and convoluted and hard
to understand
but one term that is not hard to
understand is what
wholesale is it means exactly what the
word means in common parlance something
is wholesale
if it is sold for resale
and it is retail if it is sold to the
end user
it's just that straightforward with
electricity the ferc regulates
wholesale electricity in interstate
commerce it also regulates
interstate transmission of electricity
meaning electricity that moves across
state lines
mostly via the high voltage bulk power
transmission system so what does that
leave for the states to do well it
leaves a lot for the states to do
states regulate retail electricity it
regulates what
generation choices get made within a
state so it is up to the state of new
hampshire to decide
uh whether it's okay to build a new
natural gas power plant somewhere
or a new uh uh wind project or how much
uh rooftop solar to put on people's
roofs or
anything that has to do with what
generation and how much of it to site
and then it is also the state's job to
assure
so-called resource adequacy in other
words
is there enough generation to make sure
that all of our
needs are being met that's fundamentally
a state responsibility
and on the natural gas side there is a
federal statute called the natural gas
act
and while it does have some differences
from the federal power act
at the macro 10 000 foot level that i'm
talking about today
it's pretty similar to the federal power
act
okay i want to give you the history of
new hampshire electricity
in one slide i'm really proud of my
ability to do this especially given this
year's
emphasis on concision uh the key figure
in the history of electricity in the
united states
is samuel insel who lived from 1859 to
1938.
uh he became uh well he became the
private secretary to thomas
edison in 1881 that's how he got his
foot in the door
he moved to chicago eventually and
became president of chicago edison in
and he used his perch from the
presidency of chicago edison to build a
ginormous
uh electric utility empire that
basically stretched across the whole
country
and gave him control of essentially
every public utility with the words
public service in the name so yes
i am talking about public service
company of new hampshire
in 1892 thomas insult went before
the national electric light association
which was
the um trade association of electric
utilities at the time
and he said look we want to be regulated
it's a good idea because it will give us
protection and it will basically
guarantee us
return on investment we won't have to go
from municipality to municipality and
bribe
municipal officials anymore we can just
get states to regulate us
at the state level it's a good deal he
convinced everybody
and so essentially every state in the
country
beginning at around 1910 created a
public utility commission
to regulate electric utilities and again
the industry
asked for it that's very important to
the history of electricity
uh eventually insult controlled an
empire of 500 million dollars
he'd only invested 27 million to get
that
but the great depression came his empire
collapsed
it wiped out the savings of 600 million
uh 600
000 shareholders and congress passed the
public utility holding company act in
1935 to break up these utility empires
meanwhile insulin fled to fl uh france
and uh for trivia buffs he died in the
place de la concord metro station in
and when his body was discovered his
wallet was missing
so samuel insell the very first
important
uh historical figure in the electric
industry as i said in
the 1930s congress passed the public
utility holding company act to bust up
these big utility empires
also the rural electrification act which
created rural electric co-ops like the
new hampshire electric co-op here
and basically things sort of clunked
along very nicely in the electric
industry
as costs declined over time until the
arab oil embargo in 1978 which upended
the
industry and as a result of that in 1978
uh president carter signed the public
utility regulatory policies act
into law and it turns out that our
senator john durkin was a key player in
the development of purpa
and purpa was the very first nose uh
uh under the tent of non-utility
generation
and uh senator john durkin played a role
in
getting the provisions into place to do
that and as a result new hampshire
more than i think most other states
developed a very robust and vibrant
network of non-utility generators most
of which
used a low-grade wood to produce their
electricity by burning it
so now we have non-utility generators
beginning to proliferate
in 1988 we had what i call the big bang
which is to say
that after oh gosh 15 years
of investing money and building the
seabrook power plant
without being able to bring it online it
finally forced public service company
into bankruptcy in part because of
decisions
like the one that david suter made that
i told you about earlier
a public service company goes into
bankruptcy utility bankruptcies are bad
for customers
and uh electric rates in the psnh
service tour
service territory went way up because
psnh was bought out of bankruptcy
uh by a company called northeast
utilities in 1992
congress passed the energy policy act
which
encouraged even more development of
non-utility generate
generation uh iso new england was formed
iso new england
is a non-profit organization it's known
generically as a regional transmission
organization
it operates the electricity grid for all
of new england
and it also operates the markets through
which wholesale electricity is
bought and sold so it's a very important
organization and
note that some of what it does is
uh it assures the existence of resource
adequacy around the region now remember
that is a
state responsibility it has largely been
ceded to iso new england
this is very controversial because iso
new england is really regulated at the
federal level
and states when it comes to iso new
england
are i think kind of limited to
persuasion
and query whether that is adequate
but anyway the energy policy act had the
effect of opening up
uh generation to competition at the
wholesale level
and down at the retail level uh new
hampshire
was one of the very earliest adopters of
trying to create competition and
electricity at the retail level
by passing the electric utility
restructuring act in 1996.
another bit of trivia the 1996
restructuring act was largely the work
of two
very well-known legislators one of whom
is still in the legislature
jeb bradley he was a house member at the
time and of course now he's the senate
majority leader
but he really is the godfather of
restructuring in new hampshire along
with
clifton below who was again in the on
this very committee
st e back in 1996 eventually he went on
to the state senate
after that he became a public utility
commission
commissioner and now he is the assistant
mayor in lebanon and so lebanon is
has a very active and vibrant energy
policy agenda
and i will bet you lunch that you will
be hearing testimony
from deputy mayor below over the course
of this session
for my money the next big event was the
decision by public service company of
new hampshire
in the last throws of its owning
generation assets
to waste 400 million dollars on a
mercury scrubber
at merrimack station uh the
customers of public service company of
new hampshire are
paying 400 million of the 425 million
that psnh invested in that scrubber
even though the snh no longer owns its
uh generation portfolio and it was just
a regrettable turn of events that i'd be
happy to talk about at great length
anytime anybody wants to hear about it
and then more recently you have three uh
failed projects here in new england
one was the northern pass transmission
line that was going to slice through the
middle of new hampshire
and bring uh hydroelectric power down
from canada
and uh sell it to customers in
massachusetts because that state has
mandated the acquisition of that kind of
energy
and then there were two pipeline natural
gas pipeline projects
the ned project that's northeast direct
and access northeast
they were supposed to bring more natural
gas into new england and since we're
very reliant on natural gas generation
in new england
that was going to be helpful to the
natural gas plants but
both of those projects were cancelled
meanwhile there is the so-called missing
money problem
it turns out that when you cap the
uh wholesale price of electricity the
way we do here in new england
the opportunity for generators at
the margin that are idle most of the
year
to make enough money to operate without
losing money requires some additional
revenue stream and so
now we have a wholesale capacity market
in new england
uh it means that generators are
basically just paid to be available to
generate and there are all kinds of
fights perpetually brewing
about how the rules for the forward
capacity market
should be set and that causes quite a
bit of unrest in the world of iso new
england
and i'm sure you'll be hearing more
about that
this is a series of unfortunate events
that occurred in 2015
uh through 2018 and in the interest of
time i'm not going to go through this
except to say that in 2018 the new
hampshire supreme court made a very
regrettable
ruling to the effect that the purpose of
the restructuring act
was to reduce electricity costs to
consumers
when in fact i think justice hicks in
his dissenting opinion
actually had the right answer which is
yes the legislature is always trying to
reduce electricity costs as much as
possible
but the idea of the restructuring act
was to pick a different means of getting
there
and that means was competition so
i think the purpose of the restructuring
act was to transfer the
risk of generation investments going bad
away from consumers and onto the backs
of investors where they belong
but unfortunately the new hampshire
supreme court
disagreed and the issue became moot
because the access
northeast pipeline was canceled and
therefore we didn't have to have a big
fight over whether it made sense to put
the costs of a
natural gas pipeline into electric
distribution rates i
i to me it just didn't make any sense uh
i just want to explain briefly who the
office of the consumer advocate actually
is uh we're a group of five people there
is me i'm an attorney the statute says i
have to be an attorney
i used to be the general counsel of the
puc
uh my deputy pradeep chadopodtai
is a phd economist and a very key member
of our staff
we just lost our director of finance so
we're hiring a new one and if you know
anybody who would like to be
the director of finance at the office of
the consumer advocate i hope you will
put that person in touch with me because
i'd love to talk to them
for the last year and a half our staff
attorney has been krista
shoot who we lured over here from
vermont
she has a lot of experience
in the business sector which is very
helpful to us
because i lack that kind of experience
and then of course
the person who keeps everybody uh who
keeps everything running is our legal
assistant jamie breen
and uh you should if you call our office
you'll get her and she will help you
on top of me there's a thing called the
residential rate payers advisory board
it's a nine member board and its
principal duty is acting as a sort of a
gatekeeper
when it's time to decide who actually is
going to be the consumer advocate
my current term expires in late 2023
so during 2023 the residential
ratepayers advisory board will have to
do a lot of work
in deciding who the consumer advocate is
going to be and i'd be happy to talk
about the process for doing that at some
suitable point
i also always like to tell people who we
aren't we have nothing to do
with the site evaluation committee the
site evaluation committee
is the state body that decides uh
whether to allow the construction of
major energy facilities
there is a person
at this who appears before the site
evaluation committee called the council
for the public
he or she is supposed to represent the
public
that is her statutory duty there on the
screen it's different from
ours uh and uh
the main point i want to make is that i
don't do that i do not
the site evaluation committee is
kryptonite to me as consumer advocate i
don't go there
it's also important for the committee to
understand that back in 2012
uh the general court essentially
deregulated
a local telephone service so we have
very little to say anymore about what
your local exchange carrier does
or doesn't do and the theory i think
back then
is that competition in the telecom
industry has become sufficiently robust
that it's no longer a natural monopoly
we also don't regulate broadband
because the federal government through
the federal communications act has
preempted all regulation of broadband
so again outside my authority really
what do i perceive to be the hot
legislative
topics for 2021. well i've i've gone
through
the bills that you have all uh
introduced
and for me the big issue is what to do
about the energy efficiency
resource standard as consumer advocate i
am firmly convinced that the cheapest
way of meeting the next
unit of demand for electricity and
natural gas
is through what i call megawatts instead
of megawatts
but how to do that and what constraints
to put on
our utilities doing that well that's the
subject of those
bill numbers that you see before them
and they're among the
whatever is 32 bills that you all have
to work on over the next
six weeks another big issue for us is
community power
aggregation i think restructuring
has been largely a bust for residential
customers in the sense that residential
customers
have paid hundreds of millions of
dollars of stranded costs
that was a process made necessary by the
process of backing utilities
out of being vertically integrated
generation owning utilities
that's been very good for commercial and
industrial customers they've been able
to save a lot of money
on retail electricity i don't think
residential customers
have saved very much money at all by
migrating into the world of competitive
generators
but i think allowing municipalities to
become
to basically become the demand
aggregator for their customers and their
borders
that that has a lot of potential for
taking that retail buying power
and uh deploying it in a way that will
bring rate relief real rate relief
to residential customers but again
there's a some disputes over
what rules ought to govern how to do
that and that is the subject
of hb 315 and i most certainly will come
and
testify on the day that that bill comes
up for hearing
uh there the question of greenhouse gas
reduction goals is pending in front of
you
that's a subject i probably won't
testify about uh
environmental policy is not really
within my
bailiwick as the state's ratepayer
advocate and so it's up to you
as the general court to decide whether
we want to
make it official state policy to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions
and if so how we're going to make that
happen in our energy sectors and what
that will do to electric rates and
natural gas rates
a perennial issue is net metering and
you see that there are
that subject and there is also house
bill 371 which uh
representative harrington actually
introduced at my suggestion
it clarifies that rate cases which is
what i was just talking about and any
proceedings that have to do with rates
are subject to the administrative
procedure act meaning the commission has
to hold formal hearings
take evidence make decisions based on a
record
rather than treat them as so-called
legislative dockets the the commission
put out an
order late last year saying oh you know
we think rate proceedings are
legislative dockets i'm here to say as a
lawyer
there is no such thing as a legislative
docket unless you're talking about
rulemaking
and hb 371 will give you an opportunity
to clarify that
and again i'll be here to testify uh our
priorities as an
office for 2021 well grid modernization
is a perennial issue the puc has had a
grid modernization
uh investigation open since 2015
so that docket is now in first grade
and the commission put out a really
excellent grid modernization order
last spring which i would warmly
recommend that each of you read
it was very pro-consumer so of course
the utilities hated it
and they filed a re-hearing motion and
the commission suspended the
effectiveness of the order
and we are still awaiting the
commission's decision on the rehearing
motion it's a very big issue because
modernizing the grid
is very important the question of how
aggressive to be about deploying
advanced metering
in the electric sector is very important
to us
advanced metering allows for a lot of
data to be gathered about
electric usage on a very granular level
that enables consumers to do all kinds
of cool things like
have the kind of time of use rates that
i was just talking about
obviously if your meter isn't recording
when you're using how much electricity
on you know a 15-minute basis then
there's no way of setting rates that
vary
with the um time of day or time of year
that you use them
since the early 1990s
the concept of least cost integrated
resource planning has been
a feature of our utility law to some
degree
it is a i guess i would call it a relic
of sorts of the
old vertically integrated era the idea
back then before we restructured
was that we don't want the puc
simply to consider individual utility
investments on a piecemeal basis because
it's very easy to justify them that way
the idea is that we want utilities to do
all of their planning
on a lease cost basis so that it
saves customers as much money as
possible
while still accomplishing the public
policy objectives that we
entrust to public utilities and the
least cost integrated resource planning
process
is the way that is supposed to happen
the puc hasn't been enforcing the least
cost integrated resource
planning statute however and i've now
torn out every last bit of hair i have
over that
and i think that we need to reform the
least cost integrated resource planning
process and possibly even the statute
i've already been talking about why i
love time of use rates
i mentioned that we need to reform iso
new england
and its so-called stakeholder advisory
board which is called kneepool
i'm happy to say that the region's
governors
acting through a body they call nesco
has likewise been calling for
major reforms at iso new england to make
it responsive
transparent and accountable and i'm
looking forward to having
that discussion here and everywhere else
there are a pile of ray cases that we're
going to be dealing with this year
liberty utilities has a natural gas rate
case that they have filed
uh unitil is going to file an electric
rate case sometime this spring and there
are a whole pile of water utility
rate cases pending and the three biggest
ones are listed there aquarian which was
recently bought by eversource
uh penichak east and that's a subsidiary
of the penichak corporation
in nashua which is a really a unique
public utility in that it is an
investor-owned utility
it only has one investor though and that
investor happens to be the city of
nashua
which is a very odd situation that we
find very interesting
and then there's the uh hampstead area
water company
in the southeastern part of the state
they have a rate case too
two years ago we persuaded the
legislature
with the heroic help of my friend
representative mcgee
to pass a statute calling for the
development of a statewide
energy customer data platform there is
an
open docket at the puc to figure out how
to do that and we are slowly but surely
making progress
i think that the existence of an energy
customer data platform
is going to be key to allowing customers
to do
great things with their energy use and
again i'd be happy to talk about that in
all kinds of great detail and my last
slide
is the most excellent building in all of
new hampshire
and one of the greatest buildings in the
united states and
i'm not going to tell you where it is
you have to identify it
that is the entirety of my prepared
remarks
and mr chairman i'd be happy to answer
questions or hang around or do anything
that you think would be helpful well
thank you very much
mr crease we we sincerely appreciate
that
very informative uh presentation
i do feel obligated to point out to the
members that
well mr crease is extremely
knowledgeable about a lot of things
some of the information in his
presentation
has another another side to it another
component to it
and doesn't tell
necessarily the full story that's that's
quite so i i do want to say that i tried
to be as neutral as i possibly could but
i did
inject in a couple of places some
editorial comments
for sure and uh you're entitled to do
that
uh but we also are entitled to
point out when you do that thank you
very much
all right so do we have any questions i
see that we do have a couple so let's
start with
thank you very much for an excellent
presentation that was wonderful thank
you for
um presenting all the background to get
us where we're going
um i i did just want to kind of
do a quick follow up on what your
expectations are
regarding microgrids in specific for
residential if you could speak a little
bit to that and i also wanted to say
thank you for the beautiful image of the
yale library
uh it's actually the phillips exeter
academy library
the library uh designed by louis khan
who is the greatest architect of the
20th century he also has a building down
at yale
uh and so anyway i love louis con
micro grids so uh you know
i i think it depends a little bit on
what exactly
you mean by micro grids
uh public service company of new
hampshire made a
proposal to develop a micro grid in
portsmouth
and it kind of backed off of that and my
impression is that they are
still uh working on developing
that uh as i understand a micro grid it
is a uh basically
it's something that can exist at the
neighborhood level that would allow
that neighborhood to in certain
circumstances
island itself from the rest of the
electric grid
and basically serve its own needs either
some of the time or maybe even
all of the time and
right now we haven't really moved in
that direction in new hampshire and
i'm not aware of any current efforts
before the puc
to nudge the state in that direction
it's a really interesting question to uh
think about how reasonable it is
to allow certain discrete parts of the
utility service territory to go out on
on its own
uh to some degree so i don't know i
think it's an open question right now
thank you uh next questioner is
representative callie pitts
just a question thank you don for the
excellent
presentation will this presentation and
your slides be available to the
committee
and where will it be available
uh thank you for that question what i
would propose to do
with the chairman's permission is i will
simply
take the presentation and email it to
each of you
and i think i think it will get to miss
four that way too and then she can
uh keep it in the rec official records
of the committee
thank you doc yes that would be
acceptable
thank you do we have any uh
further questions from members of the
committee
well i would just like to thank all of
you for the opportunity to kind of set
the
stage and be the first exemplar i guess
of the substantive law that you all are
operating within and i
i'm very pleased to meet those of you
who i'm not previously acquainted with
and i hope you will all feel free to
contact me
at the contact info on my first slide
because as i said i love to interact
with legislators
representative samsic has a question
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr greece for your testimony
um you know your your mission is to
basically
be the advocate for residential
customers
um and i i don't know if this is
part of your mandate as well but um
if if we're just talking only about the
actual
cost of the kilowatt hour of energy
um that's one thing do you also consider
some of the um ancillar
costs that are pro are
are generated based on how we generate
energy and what other impacts they might
have on
our environment our health our of
indeed dependency on other sources of
energy is that
at all part of your calculations or
are you focused solely on what is the
cheapest
way of getting a kilowatt of our energy
thank you for that question
representative samsich it's a really
excellent one
my objectives as the consumer advocate
are to lower costs for customers as much
as possible
while empowering customers as much as
possible
i do not consider environmental
imperatives to be within my
portfolio of advocacy issues and so
i don't go to the puc nor do i come here
and give you advice about what sort of
environmental policy you should pursue
that said i do think that the puc really
does have environmental responsibilities
and i was very disappointed a few years
ago when i saw the puc basically say
we don't take we don't take
environmental issues into account when
we make a decision that's for the
department of environmental services i
think that's an incorrect statement of
new hampshire law
and i certainly think that environmental
implications
of energy related public policy is very
okay thank you very much any further
questions for
and allow we have uh representative
brezny
um hi uh one of the questions i have is
uh on on the slide
where you showed how the rate is
calculated and you had
operating expenses um i was wondering if
um what the incentives are for the the
providers to
lower their operating systems if they
can just submit the amount
that the expenses are and then the rate
is based on that
uh thank you that's an excellent
question uh so
the public utilities commission has
statutory authority to exert plenary
oversight of the public utilities of the
state
and it has the right to inspect all of
the utilities books and records so
the puc when a utility files a rate case
does not just take the utility's word
for
what its operating expenses are they are
investigated
and the commission asks the utilities
all sorts of questions about whether
what they're doing is
uh appropriate the standard that the uh
puc uses is prudence so if
a utility is acting in an imprudent
fashion by basically wasting money
that it then wants to recover from
ratepayers the regulator is supposed to
stop that from happening
and i that i think the puc does a pretty
good job of that the utilities know that
they're under that kind of scrutiny
and so i think for the most part they
try to do a pretty good job
of uh making sure that their operating
expenses
and their capital investments are
prudent but those
issues are typically argued about
uh very passionately within the context
of rate cases and of course we're there
too
skeptically evaluating what it is that
oh thank you and i have a follow-up
question to that if i can yes go ahead
follow up
um so what what incentive do they have
to innovate for example i understand
that
they can present their their books and
the books seem reasonable
but they can just stay stagnant at those
those expenses right
what reason do they have to try to try
something different
or even to lower the cost if they don't
have to lower the cost
why would they representative i think
that is probably the most astute
question i have heard
uh this morning so far uh that
the issue that you just raised is a very
common
and uh appropriate critique of cost of
service rate making
it has been remarked many times that it
if anything discourages innovation
and for that reason there are
alternative approaches
to rate setting that are
talked about all the time and i didn't
go into that today just because i didn't
think that i had time
but that is very much a live issue
so representative bresni uh i encourage
you to
uh have a private conversation with uh
mr crease about that uh subject someday
i'm sure you guys can have a
a lively exchange about it
okay any last questions uh time
is getting short and we need to move on
so seeing none i will uh once again
thank mr crease for his wonderful uh
presentation very informative
thank you for being here and we'll look
forward to seeing you
in the various public hearings about the
bills you mentioned in your presentation
and
other bills which i'm sure you'll be
anxious to
talk to us about indeed thank you again
very much it's been a great pleasure
thank you okay so we're going to move
along now to
our next presenter before we do so
i will remind everyone that
um if you're not speaking you should
keep your microphone on mute
uh that's the key to a good
zoom meeting no background noise
so thank you for doing that and i will
also remind everyone here
in case you didn't uh catch it at the
beginning of this session
that we will have a second of these
orientation meetings
next friday starting at 10 a.m
at that session we will have a
presentation by the department of
environmental services followed by a
presentation by the public utilities
commission
so both of those will be very
informative and i encourage you to
attend
both of those sessions
and now i will ask
the representative from iso new england
kate epson to take the floor and give us
a presentation
from iso new england kate you're on
so i see kate is online
she's still muted at the moment but now
she's sharing her screen so take it away
kate
hello can you hear me now
yes we can and can you see me
yes we can okay great um
good morning everyone thank you i'm
sorry
um you're screwed we can see your screen
but we your video
is off just so you know okay um i
was rejoined as a panelist so let me
all right thank you
i i have done zoom before so that took a
shockingly long time
apologies um okay so now you're seeing
both
correct yes we see both
okay great um
well okay good morning thank you for
that introduction
um i i'm kate epson and
i'm with iso new england i've been there
for about
two years now and i am with the external
and government affairs team
and i i specifically focus on new
hampshire and maine
so i hope that i can answer all of your
questions about iso itself
and hopefully the kind of the
intersection
between new hampshire uh and and the iso
i caught a few minutes of don crease's
presentation
so that was nice to see that he gave you
a good
context for restructuring
and iso new england and sort of where we
fit in
with new hampshire electricity policy so
here's a brief overview of what i'm
going to cover today
i was under the understanding that i'm
going to speak for about 40 minutes
and it looked like you saved all your
questions until the end
so i'll try and stop you know to give
you about 20 minutes for questions
of course uh your prerogative if you
have any clarifying questions or
questions as you go
i have no problem being interrupted so i
leave it to
to you chair to decide
okay thank you miss epson i would prefer
that we
saved all our questions for the end but
uh if anybody has an urgent need for a
question just raise your hand and
okay thank you thanks
okay so iso new england um we
are the entity in new england that is
responsible for
a few um a few
things and the main one is the
day-to-day operation
of the electric grid and i may say i may
use the term
bulk power system interchangeably with
the grid
and that is our regional network here in
new england that moves
electricity around um it includes
generation
and the higher voltage transmission it
does not include
the distribution uh system which is you
know the poles and the wires
that go directly to your retail meters
and
that is managed by the distribution
utility as don spoke about
and that is regulated at the retail
level
we also do system planning for our
regional grid
and we are regulated as don mentioned
federally by the federal energy
regulatory commission
um a couple other really important
things to know about the iso for for
those of you who this
this entity is a new um a new um
organization to learn about we're we're
set up
to be independent of any of the actors
in the electrical system so
the iso itself um is an is a technology
neutral platform
it doesn't own any of the generation it
doesn't own any power plants
it doesn't own any transmission lines
all we really own is the building in
which
we do the work um you know in a lot of
software that that helps us to do that
and then we're also independent
financially in the sense that we have a
very strict code of conduct nobody can
have investments in any of these
uh market actors in the system so um
that's an important aspect of the
neutrality
um this slide gives you a nice
overview of where the iso kind of sits
within the region and federally uh
don't don't focus on this too much in
terms of the small print
um i will also share all of these slides
with your full committee so you can
always use them
as reference to go back to they're also
always on our website but i
this is a specific slideshow i made for
all of you so i will send this around
and that will include
all of my contact information to for me
to always be a resource as you need it
um so you know you were regulated by
ferc
um but we have a lot of stakeholders
that we interact with
on a daily basis we have a stakeholder
group called kneepool which you might
continue to hear about
and that's the stakeholder group of the
market participants
you know those generators independent
generators the utilities the
transmission owners
the states have an entity where they
work together sometimes to deal with
these
regional iso issues called nesco the new
england states committee on electricity
and and then of course policy makers
like all of you as well
um so whereas iso new england is
responsible for the new england portion
of the bulk electric system we are part
of that
a much larger area and it's called an
interconnection area and what that means
is
because all of our electric systems are
in interconnected
and have to be balanced within one
another at a similar frequency
and so we're part of this eastern
interconnection
um that also includes parts of canada
and
um it's it's the second largest machine
in the world
next to the china china's
interconnection in china's grid so
it's this very very large interconnected
networks
of electrons flowing around the country
and
so here here's a zoom in a little bit
more on what new england specifically
looks like in terms of its big
transmission so that's often described
as 345
kv kilovolts um and then 115
kv 245 kv and then often below 115
uh that that stepped down and and
becomes the distribution system to some
extent but there's there are some
exceptions to that
um so we manage 9000 miles
of high voltage transmission lines um
we we manage a lot of interconnections
like i said to keep us balanced with
adjacent electrical systems um
we import and export a lot of energy
over the ties that we have with canada
and new york
on net on a given year we generally
import
about 19 percent of new england's needs
um so you know kind of rule of thumb we
tend to export
more to new york and import more from
canada but there
it's two-way flows um and then you know
81 we would generate uh
internally within new england
uh going to the next slide here
these are our three core missions that
that we
do at the iso and i met i mentioned the
grid operation
and just you know since you can't all
have the pleasure of a
in-person tour yet uh until we get
through this pandemic and we can all be
back in person here's a quick shot of
the control room that we have at iso new
england and
it's this some of you have seen it some
of you got to come last year that was a
nice field trip
and it's a very very large room the
screen is about um
maybe 60 80 feet by about 15
feet and it shows this two-dimensional
drawing of the entire electric system
and there are about six operators in
that room managing that
you know on every second of every day
and so that's the grid operation piece
of what we do
that we also importantly administer the
markets
um the buying and selling of wholesale
electricity
and we also do power system planning
um so that we can say okay what
what is our system going to need in 10
years how is load
changing how are resources changing
things like that and and clearly we're
in a time of a lot of change right now
where we're moving to
from a lot of traditional sources of
generating power
like coal and oil and natural gas to
more renewable sources of power and
since
our system is quite legacy and was often
designed
for those more traditional sources of
power there are a lot of changes that
are coming along with
managing this kind of more dynamic
two-way flow of
electricity in the system so you saw
that
um so turning to our markets now
we as as don said part of restructuring
was really to introduce competition
into our generation portion of
you know generation transmission
distribution which are kind of like the
three levels of
of the electricity sector so
you know the idea was that if we
introduce competition
two generation um
firms will firms and businesses and
power plants can compete on
cost and therefore drive savings toward
consumers
and then the risk of investments rather
than having the utility make those
investments
in a power plant that maybe becomes
uneconomic later
it would be independent entities that
have to get financing
independently and then they assume the
risk so
that risk doesn't get borne by all the
consumers of electricity which
we essentially all have to be because
it's just integral with with our life
now um and
so that drove a lot of efficiencies it
drove more transparency in price
structure
um and it drove competition and it has
driven down costs quite a bit
over time um for example last year
it you know we we speak in megawatt
hours you often speak in kilowatt hours
if you're looking at your retail bill
um so if you multiply that by you know a
kilowatt by a thousand
is a megawatt so um
we're the average price of electricity
for example at that wholesale level
uh ranges from about 30 to 40 dollars
per
megawatt hour
so within those markets that the iso
administers
they are selecting the most
cost-efficient
sources of electricity based on bids
that the owners of the electricity or
the suppliers of the electricity are
saying okay
we are willing to sell one megawatt hour
of our electricity at x price and then
there are also bids from those who want
to buy that electricity
and we have a model and a system
that that puts those bids in economic
merit order
and dispatches the cheapest sources
first
based on reliability and security
constraints
so that is how you bring you know you
bring down cost because if you want to
if you want to have
a sale you want to get cleared in that
dispatch engine and so it
gives it an incentive to drive down
costs um
and then um so that's the energy market
and then we also have an ancillary
services market
that provides some very um important
services that
beyond energy things like reserves
things like
um voltage support and some other
essentials
for the power system that probably
it's a smaller portion of market in
terms of volume of
money um and services but that that may
grow over time
um and then we also have this
interesting market called the forward
capacity market
and that is the way that new england
handles this concept that don had
mentioned um called resource adequacy
so the iso has authority
over ensuring resource adequacy on
behalf
of behalf of all the states um
and it's this interesting it's this
interesting juxtaposition because
whereas the iso this regional entity
that's federally regulated
has that authority to ensure resource
adequacy the states themselves have the
jurisdiction to choose which resources
that they want to build
so the way we have pursued
resource adequacy is through a
competitive market called the forward
capacity market
and what that does is it looks out three
years into the future
and says okay what do we need three
years from now to ensure that we can
meet
all of the needs of all of our consumers
in new england
and then it has a competitive auction to
kind of assign
assign obligations to different
resources in terms of
them guaranteeing that they will provide
some level of capacity
in the future and when i say capacity
generally that's measured in megawatts
and then when they provide the energy
they're delivering that energy and
we have an upcoming capacity auction we
have them only once a year
and the upcoming one is in february it's
always the
day after the super bowl interestingly
enough and i'm not sure why
that uh happened that way but it's
always very fun
so here's a nice uh ch bar chart showing
how
the money flows among these three
markets that i just went over the energy
market the ancillary market and the
forward capacity market
um you know the greenish teal is the
energy market
and and historically that's been where a
lot of the bulk of the money flows so
it's the it's the way you know
if you're uh a generator it's where you
know you plan on making most of your
money
but depending on what the final clearing
price also is in the
forward capacity market you um
that goes up and down uh with over time
with supply dynamics you know
for a hypothetical situation let's say
there was a year
where there were a lot of resources
looking to retire
and it looked like we might be short on
capacity
then prices might go up and then that
would attract new reese's
resources going forward because they say
okay i can
that works for my my um business model i
can build
x power plant if i know i'm going to get
these revenues combined with what i
expect to get in the energy market that
um here's a nice um
snapshot of different of some you know
more statistics about kind of how we
look at this regional energy system
we have about 7.2 million
retail electric customers in new england
for our 15 million
person population you all know the
population of new hampshire it's about
1.3 million
so that translates to maybe about five
or six hundred thousand electric
customers
i'm sure you'll hear a nice presentation
from eversource and liberty and unitil
and
the new hampshire electric co-op who are
your you know your retail
utility customers and they'll give you
more granularity
on new hampshire in that respect
we we had us we had an all-time peak
demand to give you a sense of kind of
what are we using as a whole region
that it was in 2006 it was quite a while
ago
we had a peak of 28 000 megawatts
and that happened on a summer afternoon
generally our system
peaks in the summer meaning we're using
the most electricity
on a very hot summer day driven you know
by air conditioning load
and um but we do see seasonal peaks as
well so we see
our highest all-time peak in the winter
you'll see there was about 22
800 megawatts and that was back in 2004
and um these
peaks may shift over time um for reasons
of you know electrification that may
change the dynamics of how we're using
electricity
you know will some of our heating that
is very driven by oil
propane things like that will that shift
to more electrical
heating over time how will
the ev market continue to change
so there's a there's a lot at play and
we try to forecast these trends
uh to the best of our ability using um
data from from all the states directly
there's also a lot of energy efficiency
that drives how much we use
um most of new england is very
aggressive
on investing in energy efficiency and so
that's actually driven down
driven down our regionals use of
electricity
we are seeing a little bit of a growth
rate in our 10-year forecast
in terms of overall electricity use now
going forward and
we think that is largely due to these
increasing trends toward
electrification of uh sectors that were
and then there's also significant
deployment of
behind the meter solar so you might see
you see it here as
btm solar that's what btm means it means
behind the meter
um and there's a lot there are hundreds
of thousands of those systems
around new england you know a good deal
so what you know what do what do we have
in terms of power plants
um and what do we have for you know what
do we have on standby
what can we kind of expect because we
have to keep a very clear snapshot of of
what we have to operate the system right
now we have about 350 dispatchable
generators so that means that those
power plants can respond to
orders from the iso to produce more to
produce
less they can kind of ramp up and down
there
there's generation that is less
dispatchable or moderately dispatchable
um we've made some changes for example
as
more wind came online to allow wind
to be more dispatchable within kind of a
bandwidth
of what they expect to be producing in a
given time
um but then we have a lot of uh we have
a lot of resources like i mentioned
that are not really visible to the iso
that are behind the meter as well and
those clearly are not dispatchable
we have a very large interconnection
queue of resources seeking to come into
our system i'm going to get to that
later
and then we also have a lot of demand
response resources meaning you can
change the amount of your load and that
will be treated as supply
according to dispatch instructions and
then also
more passive demand side resources like
energy efficiency
but those can also participate in our
forward capacity market
um so you know there you saw that there
are about
350 dispatchable generators but then
there are about 500 buyers and sellers
in the market so that's kind of the
universe of what we call our market
participants
um there there are billions of dollars
transacted in these markets
um so we have a very large settlements
department for example that um
you know invoices and um you know
makes payments and things like that it's
a it was
that markets were worth about 5.6
billion
for example in 2020.
all right so here's a nice chart that's
showing how our resources are really
shifting over time
the blue shows the resources that we had
um into the year 2000 and then the teal
green
bar shows the resources uh in 2020 so
you'll and this is capacity so this is
important to note because
the very next slide i'm going to we're
going to look at a similar visual but
it's going to be based on
energy so capacity remember are those
megawatts
in terms of your nameplate capacity if
you were producing
all you could at a given moment that's
the max of what you could produce
um we we had a lot of
nuclear in new england we're down to
actually two
nuclear power plants one as you know is
in seabrook here in new hampshire and
then the others in connecticut
we have much less oil
and you'll see even though it looks like
we haven't had a dramatic reduction in
terms of oil capacity
it's very very rarely run so it gives
very little energy into our system
we've had a really large increase in our
natural gas resources
slight decrease in hydro and then
renewables are growing the fastest but
it looks similar because they started
out from a very small level
so there is even though it's a rapid
change in absolute numbers
it will take a while to kind of make
gains into the percentage of the market
that they actually
hold so looking now at this
in terms of energy you'll see we still
get about 30 percent of our energy from
just those two
nuclear plants we get
less than one percent of our energy over
the course of a given year from
oil or coal so very very very little
they're generally dispatched if it's
extremely cold maybe if it's extremely
hot and those energy prices go very very
high
and then it's economic for them to run
natural gas we still get a lot of energy
from a lot of capacity and a lot of
energy
and then you'll see that in terms of
energy numbers the
hydro and renewables categories are
increasing
so another important thing to keep in
mind in terms of this
electric system that we have here in new
england is
the prices at the wholesale level are
very much
linked to natural gas prices so if
natural gas is cheap often the electric
prices are
cheap because that unit that clears the
price in the mark
you know in the whole market called the
marginal unit
that is often a gas unit and so that
will set the price for
for everyone else that is going to
provide energy in that moment
um prices have been very low and in
terms of natural gas during this
pandemic
um you'll see you'll see these spikes
we've labeled some of them in terms of
time
they are often in the winter and so
here's why that is
we um we don't have indigenous fuels
um in any in any we don't have any
fossil fuels here in new england you all
know that so we
import them via pipeline or via ship
or via train and so
the gas flows generally on pipelines but
we do import some
lng liquid natural gas
and um so those pipelines though also
supply the natural gas for
our heating load in the winter and it's
contracted to serve those end use
customers for heating
um first and so when
there is a lot of need on very cold days
and prolonged cold
that gas is generally flowing to um
heating needs
and so there's less gas available to run
electrical generation on so the prices
tend to go
up um for when those electrical
generators can actually obtain that gas
to run a power plant
and so that's why you see those links in
um so like i said
we um we have many stakeholders
and so we we are operating the grid but
we're keeping in mind um
there are a lot of state policies that
play here and they have a lot of goals
that they would like they'd like to meet
and many of them
are mandated legislatively and so
we are very much looking in new england
toward a decarbonized system for our
electrical power system
because as you can see in this chart
every state except for new hampshire has
a mandate to reduce their
carbon dioxide emissions by 80 by 2050.
um and many of the states also have a
very aggressive renewable portfolio
standards meaning
they want to obtain very high
percentages
of their electric resources from
renewable energy sources as well so
the iso takes this into account and we
say
okay it looks like a lot of the
resources that are going to start coming
online in the future are going to be
renewable for these decarbonization and
clean energy
reasons and for their policy preferences
so um what do what do we need to do to
here's here's a chart that's showing you
kind of the
renewable energy portfolio standards of
the new england states
for their class one and their new
resources so new hampshire for example
has
a four class renewable portfolio system
um so this is showing new hampshire's
class one and a little bit of class two
and then you know sim we tried to do an
apples to apples comparison
for the other states rps's as well
so okay turning to so what do we see
that wants to come in to participate in
providing electricity in new england
um we're seeing um our interconnection
queue
which is the cue that has to um
everyone that wants to interconnect with
the existing bulk power system
has to apply we have to do a study to
make sure there's no negative
impacts on the system and then you know
we proceed from there there are also a
lot of state level permits that have to
happen for these types of proposals that
we have no jurisdiction over
um but what we do is we study the
impacts to
the existing bulk power system and so
okay what do we see in that queue
the queue is very large today it has
over
24 000 megawatts in it and as i said
um our peak of our entire system was 28
000 megawatts so
significant resources are interested in
getting built here in new england
and 63 of those are wind
now that's mostly offshore wind at this
point
um much much less on onshore it used to
be more onshore but
onshores is um a lot of those have been
pulled for the q
from the queues um we also have over
4000 megawatts of solar
looking to inter interconnect and that
does not include the behind the meter
solar that we do
not have full visibility over always
um it's also
about a lot of battery storage so over
3000 megawatts of battery storage it's
15 percent of our overall
interconnection queue
there was almost no storage in the queue
even just two years ago
um two years ago if you looked at the
same
pie chart that natural gas sliver that's
in blue that's only four percent
that would have been about 60 so it's re
the dynamics have really shifted in
terms of what is looking to come online
to the system
and then that that little table you see
next to
the uh the pie chart that shows all of
the proposals by state
and our queue is actually public if
you're really interested in looking at
it on our website
you can't see proprietary information
like who specifically the developer is
and things like that but you can see a
lot of information about
what the technology is what stage is it
in um
and kind of where it is along in the
process because every
every resource is assigned a cue number
because we try to
do this on a first come first serve
basis
um just a little snapshot on storage
because it's been it's becoming
increasingly important for
for many reasons we do have some
large-scale storage on our new england
system it's pretty fascinating
it's it's called pumped hydro storage
and it's essentially
water being pulled out of a river or a
significant body of water
pumped up a mountain to a reservoir and
then it can be released
very quickly to be run through a turbine
to produce
um a lot of energy so we have
almost 2000 megawatts of that in new
england and they so they can provide
that level of power within 10 minutes
and then they can sustain that level of
power for about seven hours
so storage whether it be that type of
technology or battery storage or other
types of storage
this is going to be an increasingly
important
resource in terms of balancing our
system as we have more and more
resources that
are variable you know based on weather
or other attributes
because they are renewable sources of
power
because most of you know this but it's
just always good to remind ourselves
it's it's always been very challenging
to store electrons you know they flow in
a path of
least resistance and they need to be
consumed
as they're produced so it's
we have to balance the system in terms
of exact supply and exact demand
on every single moment in order to
maintain the reliability and integrity
of the system
so being able to store those electrons
kinetically
chemically or otherwise is is a very
powerful tool
this so the states are also pursuing um
lots of energy efficiency as i as i
mentioned
through um programs often administered
by the utilities sometimes it's a third
party
and we we will see that continue to grow
these are our forecasts
um we we do 10-year forecasts every year
so
it we're expecting at least 5600
megawatts of energy efficiency in the
system
um by 2029 uh 7 800 megawatts of
photovoltaic solar photovoltaics in the
system by 2029
and then a lot of wind about 15 000
megawatts of wind
um on the system and so you know as i
said for a system that peaked at 28 000
the
this is a lot of um this is a big shift
in kind of
the resource mix so you know why why do
we look so closely at these
at these resources like efficiency and
solar and behind the meter or in front
of the meter
because they really change the dynamics
of how we plan the system
and um there are a lot of cost
implications so
you'll see that the very top line that's
our gross peak
so if we had if we did no energy
efficiency
if we had no solar um behind the meter
pv
this that top line is what our peak
would look like over time it would grow
so that would mean okay we need more
supply over time
but that drops when you add in the next
line
you net out essentially the behind the
meter solar so you're like okay
we won't need as much to meet that peak
and then the green line is when you
also net out um energy efficiency and pv
and you see that the peak actually
starts to uh decline
over time so that means that we have to
buy less in our forward capacity auction
um we transact fewer megawatt hours in
the energy market
and um so there are significant
and uh savings on the on the consumer
end
and so similar similar dynamics for
overall energies
this is another um snapshot that shows
the
increases in the solar pv resources over
time by state so you can see new
hampshire's numbers
you can see um you can see how dramatic
massachusetts really is to this regional
dynamic and contribution of pv
they have over a hundred thousand
installations of solar
around the state right now most of that
is not visible to the iso that's
there they're essentially acting as load
reducers on the system from our
um so another um another
dynamic that is happening from
increased solar penetration on our
system whether it's
you know behind a retail meter or if
it's interconnected to the bulk power
system is
it's shifting our load curves that we
see
on any on a given day so every day
you can look at a load curve that was
forecasted by iso forecasters saying
here's what we expect
the load to look like for today here's
the
energy that we expect to clear in the
market to serve that demand
and normally before we saw a lot of
solar on our system
you would see demand work like the top
dotted line over the course of the day
see it's
very very low you know at about four a.m
this people start to wake up they start
to
get ready for work you know activity
increases
until it peaks at about lunchtime and
then there's a little
dip and what everyone's using in the
afternoon and then it kind of goes back
up for the evening a bit before people
you know start going to bed and
demand starts to drop off again for the
for the night but
now what we'll see so on a day where
it's it's sunny
it's very sunny it's cool this often
happens you can see in the spring this
is an example of a real day we saw
in may of this year um there was so much
solar on the system that the actual
demand line was that bottom one
it went the demand went lower in the
late afternoon than it had in the middle
of the night
and this is a new trend we've just
started to see in the past couple years
um demand had never gone lower than the
middle of the night
before this and then there's also a
steeper ramp you see into that similar
peak that will
happen now later in the evening um and
so as the sun goes down
we need to bring other resources online
to still keep up with that um
demand that we'll you know we'll see in
the evening from act
from evening activity
so there's a lot that we're doing um to
to track this
to incorporate it into the system to
um understand and predict in terms of
um you know we we get very large data
sets from real pv systems
so we can see how they perform on
varying weather days
and it just it it really helps the
operators have a sense on how to manage
the system
and how we can better incorporate
growing variable resources over time
and still maintain a reliable electric
system
um so the the third core
um action that we take at the iso that i
mentioned at the very beginning
now i'm turning back to is our the power
system planning
so we have to plan the power system we
have to make sure
we meet all sorts of reliability metrics
that come from
ferc and their entity that they call the
northeast electric reliability council
that sets these standards they're
they're the technical body um that that
gives us these standards and enforces
them
and so we have to do a lot of studies to
say
okay are there going to be as the system
changes as
generators retire new new ones come on
uh what do we have thermal violations
of certain lines meaning is a
transmission line going to get
overloaded in this area
because we've seen a lot of growth in
terms of businesses or homes
and now they're bringing in a lot of
power but they don't have enough
power locally to satisfy it so we look
at all sorts of changing dynamics of the
system
um we do a lot of studies that are
sub-regional so you know we do we have a
study area for new hampshire where we do
needs assessments to look at the system
within new hampshire
um one project that came out of that
process
uh was the seacoast reliability project
some of you might know about that um
that was a that was a line upgrade that
occurred in the seacoast
um for you know there was there's a big
load growth in certain areas of the
seacoast
so that was part of it um and we do
we do regional system plans
every two years 2021
is a regional system plan year we look
at the system
holistically we say okay what are we
planning to spend
and invest in in transmission what do we
think we need
how will these costs be allocated those
types of dynamics
to keep the transmission system robust
and and increasingly
as renewables are coming into the system
for example offshore wind we're looking
at things like
okay there if there's a lot of offshore
winds thousands of megawatts
and they all kind of want to come in
onto our southeastern new england
coastal area because that makes the most
sense
do we have infrastructure locally that
can accommodate that type of power
flow that onshoring of power or will we
need to build a new line
say through the cape cod area like how
are we going to get that power
from a remote point to a load center
where people need it in boston or
connecticut or other places
you you all know about um
the line being proposed in
uh to go through maine the nec c line
um and that is to bring some hydroquebec
power down through maine and um into
southern new england that that
massachusetts is
um so i went through this i'm gonna skip
that because we're down to a couple
minutes
um i'll just say you can go back to this
we've made a lot of investments in the
new england transmission system
we used to have a lot of congestion um
in the early 2000s
and that's largely been eliminated that
helps in terms of
costs of generation because the cheapest
generation can
flow where it needs to on the system to
meet load
even if it's farther away from that load
um so even though you know there's a
cost trade-off you invest in the
transmission but it may bring down
generation costs
um in terms of dispatching the cheapest
possible resource
um i just mentioned some of those costs
how it helps beyond reliability
um and how are these costs allocated
because we're
we're an integrated regional system we
if it's part of that bulk transmission
system we call the pool transmission
facilities
we all pay a share of that within new
england so even if it's a line
that like the seacoast reliability
project all
new hampshire only paid about nine and a
half percent of that line even though it
was in our state because it was part of
that bulk system
so massachusetts for example paid about
45 percent of that
those these costs are allocated sort of
based on what your
um so wrapping up you've heard me you
know speak about this throughout
we really are transitioning to a grid of
the future
there are a lot of very interesting
discussions underway
at the regional level and at the state
levels about okay what
what changes need to happen at the
federal level at the iso level at the
state level
to help make this transition as smooth
as possible as affordable as possible as
reliable as possible
um we you know do we need to look at how
our
how the markets work how the market's
rules work how do
how do we do resource adequacy you know
um
the iso is not set up to take into
account
into consideration environmental goals
but a lot of states have very
important environmental goals and
decarbonization goals
so maybe that original construct isn't
serving the purposes
that it was set up to do in the same way
and so maybe we need to take a look at
that and so there are a lot of
discussions
you know underway in that respect
and the iso you know is is very
cognizant of that and sensitive to it
and
you know uh at our strategic planning
level
we have developed this vision statement
about how we
really continue to harness competitive
markets
and all these advanced technologies and
be that neutral body
but to continue to reliably operate and
plan the grid
as the whole region transitions to clean
energy so it's a real recognition of
what the
majority of the region is looking to do
here
we have lots of resources endless
resources really our website
has has really good snapshots of what
the system looks like
right on our home page we have an
app called iso to go i'll show you
it's free you can download it you can
see what the prices are at any given
moment
you can see what the demand curves look
like as i showed you in that one chart
i i recommend it it's a fun app it's
very user friendly
and we do um lots of publications we do
an annual
uh rely regional electricity outlook
that's very
visual good graphics and we do some
state profiles so
with that i am happy to take any
questions thank you
thank you very much mrs epson as usual a
very
thorough and interesting presentation
i'll start off the questions for you one
of your slides talk about 24
129 megawatts of wind
and i've been noticing that existing
ppas that have been submitted
or have been signed rather by both
massachusetts and connecticut
are showing prices for that offshore
wind
between 78 and 98 dollars per
megawatt which is considerably higher
than
the average price of a megawatt today
does iso new england
forecast significant increases in the
price of electricity over the coming
years
um so just to be just to clarify so that
the total
interconnection queue is 24 000
megawatts and then wind is about 15 000
megawatts of
that and
in terms of those power purchase
agreements that are being signed in
massachusetts and connecticut
and rhode island those are power
purchase agreements being signed
with their um retail
ute electric utilities so those costs
will be born
not at the wholesale level but at the
um state level based on how those
contracts are entered into
so in terms of overall
um forecasts
on um electric you know wholesale market
prices
um we we aren't specifically
expecting to see them increase
we've seen a declining trend over time
and generally a lot of these
technologies that are coming online
we're also seeing the price
okay thank you next is representative
jd bernardi
done mute here uh yeah so uh with regard
to reliability
uh what do you have any involvement
in uh hardening the grid for emp
or is that off your uh responsibility
list
we are aware of that issue very much um
you know there are a lot of security and
reliability risks that we analyze
um so yes that does fall under
our purview a lot of cyber security
risks now too that are being looked at
the iso is increasingly you know has an
increasingly large cyber security team
don't forget to unmute say all that
again now
thank you uh chairman rose and thank you
kate for an excellent presentation
very helpful for some context um
and the changing is is of interest to me
in how we're approaching our work this
year um net metering efforts and several
different
bills are coming up uh this year again
in the legislature
and i understand that in december the
iso came out
to discuss the um
the categorization i guess of behind the
meter assets
which we can't really see and use in
terms of our
overall energy landscape but we can
figure out whether to designate them as
load reducers and you mentioned in your
presentation
that that was how you look at those
assets
so it may inform some of our
conversations later in the session
if you could just say something about
that december discussion and decision
at the iso because i think it was kind
of a nebulous area for us in the last
session when we discussed how those
assets are looked at
in terms of what they're doing for the
system sure
so there are a couple components so when
we operate the system we often see them
as
load reduction but i think the issue
that you're specifically referring to
is that of reconstituting behind the
meter
generation into regional network load
which is a trans
it's a transmission metric in the
transmission system rather than the
looking at the generation um part of the
system so
the our independent market monitor came
out with
a report this summer and they said
we think there may be a compliance issue
where the
transmission owners are
not reconstituting the load
of the behind the meter generation into
this regional network load
and subsequently the transmission owners
put together a proposal to reconcile and
fix that compliance
issue and so that is actually
in process right now in our stakeholder
process
and they're looking at okay
apparently their practice has generally
been
to not reconstitute the load and treat
them as load reducers
and they would like to continue to do
that
so they're looking to modify the tariff
to reflect that practice
but that's um that is still under
discussion at the stakeholder process
there's been no official filing at ferc
to make those changes um
but is that what you were referring to
yes yeah
okay yeah because i think that
that's opaque to us right now yeah it's
very it's very technical
and it has implications mostly on kind
of um
how costs are allocated and you know
what are the benefits
what are the costs if we're reducing
those monthly peaks
um how should we you know how do we take
that into account in the system so
that's what the transmission owners are
looking at really
more than the iso itself since they
they're
they own the assets they really um have
all the data
um and so that's ongoing and i'm you
know i'm happy to continue to update
folks on that because that's going to go
on for the next few months i would say
thank you okay uh
uh thank you chairman vos uh
ms um epson i have a question on the
and is the
um you have the dotted line
which is the the peak power demand
and the solid line on the bottom
is that um
with the use of solar behind the meter
or just
all solar um
so yeah let me clarify it's a good
question so the dotted line at the top
is what the demand would have been
absent behind the meter solar but the
bottom line is what we actually
saw as demand because
the there was so much solar on the
system reducing that demand
all right and a follow-up question um
right now i mean battery development has
become such a big thing for behind the
meter
it seems to be growing exponentially
is is there any anticipation of
uh what that's going to do to peak
demand
uh at the end after the sun sets
i mean i think that the idea and the
hopes are generally i'm just generally
speaking you know for
you know what we're seeing in kind of
technology innovation is that
the that storage can that is paired with
solar or standalone
can help with that ramp that solid line
we see
and help bring down that evening peak as
the solar comes offline
so that it wouldn't the system wouldn't
be as reliant on other
say natural gas resources or other
fossil fuel resources that can
um dispatch quickly and ramp up
to accommodate that demand that is
you know coming back online as the solar
tails off so
um i you know i just read an article for
example this morning that said
about two-thirds of solar now come
proposing to come into the system
um you know nationwide is being paired
with storage
so it looks like you know people are
understanding this dynamic here shown in
this chart and
and it it looks like that there you know
there's going to be
uh these dual assets and these paired
assets increasingly to help kind of
manage those ramps and those peaks
thank you okay
next up and don't forget to unmute
yourself
representative samsich
yes uh thank you mr chairman mr chairman
i have
two two questions for miss epson uh
it's epson uh the simpler question is um
i noticed from your diagrams that it
looks
as far as the future predictions are
concerned
that energy efficiency makes a big dent
in in energy uh energy demand
resulting in energy demand so that's my
first question my second question is a
little bit more
regarding the power system planning and
that is i've heard a number of people
discussing the idea
of of perhaps implementing
as a national infrastructure project
a separate additional grid
a transmission grid for renewable energy
similar to the national highway system
which would be complementing
the current grid have you heard any of
that discussion
so on your first point yes um energy
efficiency is making
um a big difference in in energy
and peak demand if that if that was your
question
yes that's true um i so
i have read in the press too that
there are a lot of discussions underway
about a you know a federally
um proposed type of
interstate transmission system as well
um you know in terms of moving
renewables say like wind from the
midwest
to the east and there are a lot of
reports that actually look at that
and there was a very recent report i
think that looked at that
it's not an iso report it's a it's a
consulting report
that looks at the cost differential
of doing um meeting clean energy goals
if they're federally coordinated
versus state by state by state and the
efficiencies you'd see
and kind of having that organized
transmission system
rather than kind of a one-off built
transmission system so yeah there's
there's a lot that's under discussion i
would say nationally
about how how are we going to
interconnect renewables
and how are we going to maybe move them
around in a way that helps
mitigate some of the variability by
region
thank you very much um
representatives samsung pimentel if you
could
lower your hands now that you've asked
your questions and next i'll call on
representative uh homoa
yes thank you so much for your
presentation and for giving us this
information today
the question i had was do you have any
information on the overall
cost of utilities in states say like
vermont who have very aggressive
renewable policies
how has that benefited the consumer
thank you so much
sure um we we do keep track
of the differences in retail electrical
rates
in each of our states mostly for
educational purposes
and as part of um another group that we
coordinate called the consumer liaison
group um
and so i'm i'm not i i do have an
appendix with me today so if you don't
if you want to
not look while i scroll really quickly
but
we do have the comparison of retail
rates by the states and
so we don't i don't necessarily want to
attribute it to this policy or that
policy
um and it looks like we i don't have
that slide in here
but i do have that information that
slide
and i can get that to you and what i
will say off the top of my head is
um i believe vermont has slightly lower
rates
now something to keep in mind is they're
not they did not restructure
so their utilities um are bundled still
they own the generation the transmission
and the distribution so that's just one
factor
to consider though they they do have
aggressive policies
and i think new hampshire is
about the in the middle like we have the
fourth
highest retail electric rates but in
another
sense the third lowest so you know it's
we're kind of in the middle
connecticut and massachusetts have the
higher retail electric rates
of the region thank you
okay thank you very much and uh
thank you sue i mean uh kate epson for
uh your presentation here today we're
just about
out of time uh for our zoom
session here and i would like to close
this
uh meeting by reminding members that uh
we will have another one of these
presentations next friday starting at 10
a.m it'll be
very similar to the one we're having
here today
i urge you to be here if you can
and i'm sure most of you are wondering
when will we have
our first public hearing well
we don't know the exact answer to that
question
but we do know it will be no earlier
than
january 25th the week of january 25th as
being
uh we're being told is when
the vast majority of public hearings
will begin
there will be a couple of public
hearings next
week but those public hearings
are considered to be trial hearings to
test
the systems that have been set up by the
house staff and the house leadership
uh to get public hearings going
the hybrid model public hearings uh
started and
you know iron out the kinks so there
will be a couple scheduled next week but
we won't be allowed
to schedule our first public hearings
until the week
of january 25th so
it's possible that it could be that day
monday the 25th
depends on what day we're assigned and
we won't know that uh
for a while yet i don't expect to get an
answer to that today
so it's likely we won't know the answer
to that
until sometime next week obviously we
need to
have an answer by next wednesday because
that's when
notices need to go into the calendar for
the following week
so it's likely we'll know by next
wednesday possibly sooner than that
as soon as i know i will let all of you
know
representative oxenoum you have a
question
i do mr chair thank you very much for uh
taking the question
it's actually sort of a plea if if you
are in negotiations about what day
if you could please not make it monday
january 25th that's a puc technical
session
on energy storage and i will be very
much bound up in and i would hate to
miss
or be put into the front situation of
trying to be in both places
at the same time okay i'm not
sure that that's a good negotiation
we may be assigned a day
but if i have a chance to to advocate
for one day or another i will
i will keep that in mind thank you very
very much you're you're most welcome
representative callie pitts don't forget
to unmute yourself
get everything is it is it possible that
we
as an st e committee can have
either a web page or so that
all our information all these
presentations
copies of bills and everything can be in
the same place
rather than having to go into our
personal emails or
how to skeletal looking for them um
just thought an excellent suggestion
let me ask jen for
if that's uh something that might be
possible jen
i'm not sure i'm not sure about
like a separate web page um i would say
that the committee webpage that exists
now
is a great place to go um if you want to
locate
bills currently in committee you can go
to the
um standing committee page and then
select
science technology and energy and then
there's a button that says
bill's currently in committee so that's
helpful in that respect
in terms of other materials that's
definitely something that our staff
is thinking about and asking about but
i'm not sure
how long it would take to develop so
stay tuned
um we're definitely on the same page as
as you guys
um but of course as always limited
time and resources to build that sort of
infrastructure
thank you good thank you i did kate
epson leave already
i apologize i forgot to ask her if she
could provide us with a
copy of her slides i suspect they're on
the iso new england website
i will send her email and ask her if she
could send us a link
representative thomas uh thank you mr
chair for taking my question
this question is really for jen really
actually for the benefit of of our clerk
um what is the status of our committee
assistant
and how is that going to work with our
there will be committee assistance
assigned to each committee um
as usual i'm not sure who your committee
assistant was in the past
it was carol stapler okay um i'm not
sure
that she will be back um but there will
be coverage i've seen
a draft uh model but i don't want to say
any names until we're for sure
but you definitely will have a committee
assistant assigned to the committee who
can
help processing bills and coordinating
with the clerk
definitely thank you
thank you uh representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman yes uh to follow
on with
um representative kelly pitt's point
i was wondering if our current if our
existing page might be the place where
something could be added on
also for the public in terms of where
they would go
to locate not only information about
upcoming bills but also how they would
interact with us
because i think the question that's out
there for them is
how do they make people aware that
they're planning to testify
do they use the committee email to
submit their testimony so there needs to
be some answers around
the public process i guess and that's
the last thing i would bring up on
on that we hadn't covered i thought
a good point uh there's a lot
of questions i'm sure that you guys have
and
we're all in the same boat i have
similar questions
uh there are no answers yet but i'm told
that
answers to those questions are under
development
as far as a website is concerned that's
a resource
issue you know who would be the person
in that would own that website
i'm not sure that how staff has the
resources to do that kind of work
i suspect with joel anderson's departure
how staff
is under resourced at the moment
jennifer you could
uh nod or shake your head
if that's the case um yeah i thought so
so
uh it would be a nice to have
i'd love to have it myself um
i i just don't know who we could get to
operate uh that particular website so
it's worth looking into i will pursue it
but i can't
obviously make any promises about it
alrighty it's been a wonderful meeting
it's been great to see
everyone i'm sorry we didn't get a
chance to do introductions we will
make it a priority to do that next
friday before we get
involved in our presentations and
i'll look forward to seeing you all at
that time
and representatives yes yeah this is
representative callie pitts for those of
us who've been on the committee and
those of us who
haven't been on the committee is there
any way we can
either send our greetings or thanks to
joel
uh i know i've put him through hell over
many years
so is there any way we can send our a
thanks to him
as a committee i'll defer that question
um i don't have his his personal email
at my fingertips um
i would certainly be happy to kind of
forward things on if you want to send
me anything um
that might be the best the best
announcement to make right now
and how do we get in touch with you jen
my first name
jennifer j e n n i f e r dot
four f o o r
at l e g dot state dot
n h dot u thank you
and could we send as a committee a get
well card to
representative clinton express our our
concern about his
health and yes with his puns amongst us
we can send cards to representative
plett he is at
the rehabilitation hospital i forgot the
exact name of it but it's at 254
pleasant street in concord it's on the
thank you you're welcome
well i'm going to suggest that uh we
call it a day
once again thanks everybody for being
here and we will see you
next friday take care thank you mr
chairman thank you thank you thank you
mr chairman
thank you okay thank you thank you mr